but she's wearing the 95s there max you
get me i feel like i'm rolling with the
man then what's going on
95s come on cuz but other than that
she's good
dms dating apps i don't have time for
that
i don't believe you should kiss a lot of
frogs to find your prince i believe
in grilling them i'm gonna be going on a
series of dates to find who
can really wow me this is thrilling
yes my people your boy tyler logan don't
ruin it with doing it
that's enough thirsty brothers on this
show here thirsty a couple of my
bedrooms all involved that's why i'm
here because i'm looking for love
even though i'm here yeah a bit of
entertainment no i'm here for love
she can ask me whatever she wants to ask
me because i'm gonna ask her what i
wanna ask her
come on let's get straight into where
she my babes where is she
yeah i got a warm heart though sure yeah
100
look you've been smiling they haven't
been here 10 seconds cause i'm be honest
with you i'm not too sure about them
gala
you get me no everyone just comes with
looks i'm looking for more than looks i
told you i'm here looking for love
why these men keep wearing tracksuits
we're saying it's a whining thing it is
cheers cheers you see what i'm saying so
i'm talk good energy good spirit i'm not
really used to the wine stuff though
so what's your name ty what's your name
cheyenne
see you you've done good you've done
good today nails
hair yeah i like it is that a fake
compliment if you could just stand up
i'll give you a proper compliment
like i just want to look i can't see
what you're wearing i can't see
yeah you're right so tell me about
yourself ty i'm a young
black independent actor entertainer
model
what would you vote yourself out of him
in terms of what sorry looks
i think that's a hard one because god
told me that everyone's beautiful in
their own way
how much would you rate yourself if you
remind me of skin 10
why why wouldn't i no of course
self-loving
self-love brother my girl said she's a
10.
i'll be real with you i'll be real with
you
she would have been a 10.
but she's wearing the 95's there max you
get me i feel like i'm rolling with the
man then what's going on
95s come on cuz but other than that
she's good but i'm upset forget all this
smooth talk i'm upset with you darling
because you see you getting here today
it was mad i was meant to throw in the
suit
yeah i was wondering why you're wearing
that but you're wearing them you're
wearing what's your
max 95's today geez the one do you not
think nice you look nice
why are you shouting now i'm not
shouting stewart and i told you you
shouldn't have right one sip
lightweight calm down you've been dating
all my friends
i'm thinking i'm the first one to get
here you're doing day after day after
day after day i'm thinking i'm not
special
why is that an issue because you're
dating my friend where's your friend get
your phone back let me do it your
friends
say you're trying to date me yeah right
and then it doesn't work out but you
then start moving to my friend
it's very common in men yeah that if it
didn't work out with me you then move to
the friend
no i think that's a bit jokey to be
honest i can't really speak on that
you've never done that
in my time i've probably done that in my
younger years
not as a grown man there's a lot of
things if you ask me i'll tell you i've
probably done
as a young man i want an angel but i
think the more experienced the man has
he knows what school he knows what's bad
you don't want to chat to a man that's
not got any experience do you
what's the worst thing you've done to
try and [ __ ] a girl to be honest you're
not chatting to a young man that's
um ever and you see me i'll never sell
dreams i'll never lie to a girl or
gas off a girl to make her think you're
sat in a just to get a bit of sex so
what do you do then
i'd be myself i'd like to think he's not
going to sell me dreams
but i don't know they all do sometimes i
might just do the matching i might just
say babes you're right you're right
how you doing you're good no you do not
throw that can i go for your phone
where's your phone let me see what's
going on over there my friends here my
girls playing games let me see that
bring that
raw tyrone is that what you're doing
so that's not my fault
who's that tyrone
even you sitting here right now you're a
sweet one
but what you need to understand there's
a million sweet ones but
a lot of girls in this generation they
don't understand that yeah but this is
the problem that's the problem
no but you saying there's a million
sweet ones yeah that's what i'm saying
so already
because you're missing what i mean i
don't care for your sweet one there's a
million sweet ones
meaning i don't care about your looks
what other stuff have you got
what have you got you got personality
are you caring
are you loving are you affectionate do
you family orientated
do you like kids do all these other
stuff
you've got a cover i don't care if
you're pretty what else have you got
are you going to be caring you're going
to talk to me are you understanding
things that really matter in an idol
situation like i would love a man to
think like that
yeah but the reality of it is you guys
don't like i can't talk for other men
me you no one else
let me not chat rubbish because i'm
being real honestly honestly honestly
i'm being
real if i'm talking to someone and i
like someone
of course i'm gonna give everything to
that someone like i said to you i would
love to be in a relationship i would
love to that's my aim i've been single
two years over two years
i was in a four or five-year
relationship what do you have to offer
do you know what yeah i'm not a
millionaire yet but i'm on my way that's
a materialistic aren't
you one of them shake mine again shake
my hand again because you see what we're
doing here today
i like you when i shook her hand my
girl's coming strong
she'll try and rip my hand off blood you
get me gotta take it easy with them gal
let me get that strong
when you're in the bedroom it might all
go wrong yeah
that's why you should never judge a book
by its cover so you judge me all right
cool
i can only talk based on my experiences
a lot of experience i've had in the past
darling
is that a lot of pretty girls they don't
offer much apart from
looks he loves the word darling doesn't
he i'm not sure how i feel about that
i'm not your darling
but do you think you can give much yeah
what can you give motivation
inspiration inspiration time time
good sex in bed
you sure you want to get into that
conversation i tried my best
you see that babes i don't even like to
talk too much because you probably get
loads of guys that talk oh yeah yeah
listen you see over here long long yeah
long long i don't really want to talk
because this might be kids watching
long long you see that one there but i
don't even know how to explain it but if
you know
you know you see the long long it's like
how can i explain it
it's like boom so would you say you're
aggressive
it can be i'm a very um flexy person
meaning you can float
if you want me to be the cool chilled
guy i'll be the chill guy you've got to
do [ __ ] i don't even talk
you sit here like that do you know what
i'm saying hey dean you're how are you
doing
sweet so who's there you then that is me
i'm just a mixed personality person
some days you'll catch me on moody some
days you'll catch up yeah yeah
yeah you know what i'm saying makes you
a good person i feel like
i'm very understanding i'm very caring
i'm loving
affectionate i'm a people's person means
that i make people smile
my job is to make people happy
what do you think is your toxic trait
not caring i could like that's really
bad i'm not
not careful but i am i'm care i've told
you i'm caring i'm loving but i have
this way of
even if i care about you don't care nah
i could care but not care
i could care about my ex for example
i'll tell you that one i loved her
i did i thought was the one first love
first level four was the one however i
still got rid of her even though i loved
her
why because i've got morals and
principles that i live by
and i've been growing up i say are you
jamaican i'm jamaican so certain things
we don't condone i see you with me news
together for example
and you wanted to do some mad [ __ ] that
i didn't really condone it
what's mad [ __ ] you're doing drugs
you're chatting to this you do all over
the world
you're not answering yourself
yeah whatever you do you're gonna raise
my daughter to do it
i don't want my daughter doing that do
you know what i'm trying to say rob
it's crazy man i want my daughter doing
that so you see if you're doing that
stay over there i ain't got nothing
wrong with you i've got friends i got
from
loads of people that probably do drugs
but my companion
the woman that's going to raise my
daughter
what's going on partying like all over
the gap okay
you get me baby i'm in birmingham yeah
because i'm in manchester using
birmingham yesterday baby yeah i'm in
manchester i'm going
so you want that just a woman just to be
at home and wait for you no see you're
missing my point
you see me if i was with no relationship
my girl can go partying
do that you just got you just like
there's a difference between
partying and doing drugs but i mean
anything that i don't condone
i don't want my girlfriend to do but i'm
not going to get upset and start calling
my girlfriend first come on
no i'll just get away from it like leave
the situation
yeah so do you not think that
communication is key like in order for
relationships to work that
it's actually better just to sit down
and yeah but when you've done that three
four five
six times you're ruining it that's what
it is i bet you show me if you can
do that do that give your lips what do
you want me to do
you're ruining it say your root you put
your lips into it
no no
so when was your last relationship years
ago years ago
why why are you titan like that how many
years
good for you what's a good few four five
six yeah about four years
red flag red flag
look at me why are you single
for that many years and what was you
doing in them years what have you been
doing
what are you up to what you've been
doing
you genuinely just waste my time you
sell dreams it's all this [ __ ] and
then you're linking five
women at the same time like i'm not on
that messy do you do that unless you no
i don't do that
how many women have you looked at one
time nah man if i'm linking someone i'm
linking someone but it depends what you
call lincoln
you could link multiple women within one
week
what do you mean by linking them though
do you mean like having sex is that a
link yeah
yeah saying i've been really bad in my
past in my young days i was crazy i'll
tell you some madness but what about now
now i'm good no i'm a young man i'm
working i've got my career i'm focused
i'd love to find that i'm a girlfriend
that could just be really grown
yeah you don't know down there i was in
a four to five year relationship
would you be with me if my past was in
the porn industry
i would really really really have to
like you still and it depends how
near it was if you're telling me it was
two years ago i'm not going to lie to
you i'm being honest with you darling
you want me to lie to you you'll be
honest with me no be honest i'm being
honest i'm not
being dead honest with you if you told
me it was like two years ago
ah it's gonna be very very hard but you
see if i was invested with you and i had
like a deep connection with you
i'll do my best to try and like if i
liked a woman that much
where i wanted her about my daughter to
be like raised by her and i liked her
that much i'll
try my best to try and look past it look
perfectly it would be hard still
porn yeah porn
it's a hard one you watch porn
yeah what one did you watch [ __ ] you
know
um interracial
big batty big tits squat
i shouldn't even be talking that you got
me talking mad why are you drawing me
out for you've got me doing the math
what porn do you watch
you don't watch porn why because it
gives you unrealistic expectation what
sex is
because then we get guys that think
they're really good in bed and they're
really not did you say you're a
family person that's number one number
one's mum
you know what i'm trying to say you
always got mom's first that one there
whole different category
like you see my girl and my mom they're
two different
i would never put a girl before my mum
certain man
a taking gal places their mom has never
been
never experienced it never seen it never
even
heard of it how can you take a girl that
you've met on instagram where you've
just met her today to a nicer place than
your mom's ever ever been
how can you take the girl to the chart
and your mom's never been to the shop
he is a very strong contender i can't
lie
maybe the strongest there is obviously a
balance i'm not some [ __ ]
mommy's boy that flip mom what should i
do
it's not that however mommy always comes
first or even me working
that's for family for me i haven't even
got kids but it's like i still
work like i've got kids i'm thinking of
my grandchildren
so all this trip stuff in it that family
is such a big family that is such a big
thing
i think of my grandchildren now and i
even got kids yet
would you say you're emotionally
available what do you mean by that being
able to be in tune with your emotions
and how you feel
yeah what about you yeah of course but i
feel like it's more of an issue with
guys that's why i wanted to just be sure
that you are yeah but you know what it's
done and i feel like the way you're
talking here right now
it sounds like you don't think females
have probably you think there's no crazy
females out here of course there's a lot
i'm trying to say like how do you think
sometimes when men move a certain way
is maybe because of their past
experiences or their last girlfriend
that that was dealing with or a girl
that done them dirty
okay but that's why i'm asking you me i
beg you just
like can you when was the last time you
cried a year two ago
says nothing's upset you all the time i
had an audition over there didn't get
the wrong
journals for my whole life would have
changed
missed out on it it's right there we
move so how do you deal with it how do i
deal with it yeah like when all these
things are going wrong
how do you deal with it because surely
if you're not expressing you just kind
of build up build up build out and just
have like a crazy breakdown this is why
it's important to be emotionally
available
i feel like i am doing because i don't
know i talk to my friends talk to my
family
my people i have fun as well i do have a
lot of fun even though i work hard
i feel been doing all these things i
promise you i have fun i'm a fun guy do
you have any fetishes
no i like boobs i like bum i like eyes i
like tea i don't even know if that's a
fish i like teeth like like
i just like these things you have
fetishes so i say you watch porn you say
i'm not someone that watches it every
day no that's not me darling that's not
maybe once a month one of you has a
fetish
one hundred percent cause i told her
what i like
but it's not fetish you like what fate
see the whole foot thing everyone's on
this whole foot thing
you see me darling i'm gonna be real i
don't care
whether the girl's looking like beyonce
looking like i don't care how you look
you see when it comes to that feet stuff
i'm not putting a girl's foot in my
mouth to do what
to jam for what why are we eating toast
now bear man doing these
i don't eat tall why are you eating tofu
what do you eat then i don't eat none of
that i told my
ready before i come on the show i don't
eat none of them things
what do you eat stuff what are you
eating that's what you don't eat putting
no he was doing so well until he said no
to that
and i'm not sitting there i'm not listen
let me just give you the breakdown when
i was younger because i'm jamaican as
well the way we got raised up
no no you're jamaican as well you know
are you gonna ask me you know but then
same time
as i've got older i understand do you do
it
no you see if i was in a relationship
and i love that woman
i'll do it whatever it is i'll do it but
because i haven't been in love
no because i haven't i would but i
haven't done it i ain't found that
i can't i've never done it never i've
tried
i've tried it to my ex no i mean i've
tried like in my brain
no that wasn't it it's like i trust i
was in a four or five year relationship
of course i tried but i wouldn't have my
brain is like yo i want to do it
but my body's like i don't i can't ah i
can't
because i told you already man it's all
a madness bro
it's not really my team man's from
jamaica because you don't believe in
certain things my brother
you get me but whoever does whatever you
do
do you go do you know what it is because
they've got big lips they assume
you know what i'm trying to say because
i've got big lips they think yeah
he's doing that he's in the grouches in
the grooves
i'm not in the grooves not
i'm never going to be the guy that
doesn't do that i'm sorry what are we
ten
i did try i would go without it
i would go with that i'll go without if
that means i've got i'll go without
let's go without you want to do it just
not do it i'll never
pressure my girl into doing it's not
that deep that's good
i'm really impressed with that yeah what
about you do you suck
i was in jamaica and i met this girl
from brooklyn yeah new york
i said yeah i was ready for it
we're in jamaica now at one event night
time in the seaside playing games i
brought her back to my hotel
and i tried bringing her in in the
shower see let me give you some advice
when you have sex with someone the first
time
never have it in the shower yeah because
it's messy it's
it's still slipping that was kind of
short as well so it's all slipping
sliding
mess next day she'd come round she said
hey man that was some wack-ass dick i
said
what man's never heard that before i've
never heard that before
never i only go for older women yeah but
this i'm saying because you watch porn
and it's giving you an unrealistic
expectation
yeah but when you're making it so i told
you already i don't watch phone every
day i might watch it once a month
like even see porn it keeps me from
making bad decisions
enough girl or people they call their
exes yo baby what's going on yeah come
right [ __ ]
just because they're roasting and they
own a bit of sex and i'm gonna tell all
the men
any men actually females as well because
i know there's certain females out there
you get me oh yeah make a ha calling
their ex on that or calling that old
thing
but forget all that you see
if you go if you watch a bit of porn do
you got to do and you still got that
feeling
then make the phone calls but sometimes
you make the phone calls
before we've even done what we got to do
and you see me when i do what i've got
to do
i don't even need that anymore you're
thinking ah
all that time energy yeah wait cut all
of that out
and just watch a bit of bomb yeah it'll
save you a lot of time and money
so how much money do you make if i tell
you i'll be telling everyone else about
be good but as i said to you money
unknown image thing enough man yeah baby
good over here yeah i see money
see all of that i'm on a whole nother
thing babes
i've got big plans i'm trying to say i'm
trying to buy a house i'm trying to open
up a [ __ ]
like there's so many things i've got to
do and if i buy all this strip i'm not
going to be able to open up my [ __ ]
restaurant
i'm not going to be able to buy um buy a
house i'm not going to be able to set up
my other business you know what i'm
trying to save for all the money's
getting on drip so what do you want do
you want the millions or do you want the
image stuff
okay but the way you portrayed yourself
in the beginning is like i don't care
about materialistic
you all care about materialistics i
don't think we do
i reckon you all do
no nah but same time you better be
doing saturn don't just think you can
come here and sit down and come to my
yard foot update
if i'm with someone they don't need to
have money on that but you need to be
working towards sand
you're getting whether you're flipping
studying trying to get your degree and
[ __ ]
and you've got a part-time job or you're
working on your new little business or
you've got a job when you're working on
your business on the side
you have to be doing something there's
no way i can have because i've worked
look i got
work tattooed on my hand used to go over
again but
so how can i be so on work mode and
my girls just on some yeah babe what
time are you going to be on
i need more than that before i'll be
honest with you i would love a housewife
i would love a housewife
i'll go out and grind and make sure
dinner's ready bath set candles lit i
love a candle
how come there's no candles let's scare
them oh yeah yeah you're great i didn't
even see it because it was all in
my girl she just needs to be working i'm
not saying she's got to be making
big money no because we will get there
but you have to be working you've got to
be doing
something you can't just be sitting at
home or on instagram looking good
yeah i don't care about none of that
image stuff i care about real life would
you be
bothered if she earned more money than
you nah that's sick
loads of my friends made more money than
me you getting
your partner yeah that's fine friends
family wherever
you go partner no that's making me go
harder
you know what i'm trying to say i feel
that even if my partner did earn more
money than me
i would still be paying for [ __ ] and
patting
no why not no why i just feel like
there's no need for it why do you need
your partner's phone possible
you think it's it's not to snoop or
anything i just think in general like
it's because if it was that bad why
don't you just ask your part your babes
i'm not your phone just think in general
like
there's nothing to hide so what's the
issue no that's true man if it would
cause a problem i'll say yeah take it
take it but initially yeah babe what's
your password yes my part and we're both
just on the travis phone and shits
ah that's toxic who's this are you
seeing you go on your partner's phone
you're automatically looking on the
search
you can't help it but that's more of a
trust issue like no i don't think it's a
trust issue so
i'm saying but if you're going through
someone's phone and you're looking for
that that's an insecurity
so are you insecure no but why am i on
your phone both
there's no reason i got my own phone
i've got i've got people have this i
don't want you to use your two fans yeah
should i say about pepperdine phones
yeah go and drag they are so popular
yeah i'm popular very popular
what's that now take it anywhere you
want what's booty please that's massage
yeah man like that yeah well you let the
rub down what's your preference though
like in terms of all this beauty stuff
let's drain what's my preference how
would you like to be on your site
massages is this what it means yeah
what's it called again booty what
booty pleasures play booty play yeah
what what did you think how you want i
just like a little massage oh is that's
all you like when it comes to the beauty
yeah do you like getting your bum
slapped
don't mind it and you seem like the type
like when you have if someone wants to
slap your bum
i just feel like you're a target mothman
what's that what did you do
apparently actually i'm doing it two
card answers i'm gonna do two as well
but tell me
why why you're doing two and i'll tell
you what i'm doing too is
yes as in i probably would like it just
in general but not thinking like i don't
intentionally like people's
pictures to spite like a partner but i
would i say no as in
ideally when i'm with someone i don't
actually look at other people
and this is like a friend so i probably
would like their stuff and support it
that you might get jealous about
just know anything you do i can do 20
times
so you're paying no i'm not would you do
something
i wouldn't i wouldn't that's minor man
come on like in a picture
that's some baby business if i'm with
someone and i really like someone and i
love
someone it takes a lot for me to like
just break up and
throw it in the bin because you work
that's why i got tight work you have to
work on it if you're in a relationship
and you don't like a couple of things
you've got to work on it you can't just
throw the whole thing in the bin do you
know what i'm saying so
in terms of liking pictures that's some
baby [ __ ] man
what would you do if my ex was after you
after me
tell them forget about it it's gonna
cause yourself headaches
long allow it forget about it you've got
my back like that
yeah well after you or me well he's
after you because of me
oh yeah we're good babes don't worry
about that it's not worth it in the
comments and you realize that it weren't
worth it isn't going to go home and just
never talk to you again
facts trust me top security oh yeah come
on man
discuss light this light it's crazy
you're gonna make man start picking up
weapons and that
how do you think the date's gone to be
honest with you i've i've just been
myself you know i'm just cool i'm
chilling
i thought you was gonna be a bit more
but you was good
you've been looking in my eyes though
you see the way you're like you're in
you're not just looking at me you're
looking in me
so it's been kind of hard to deal with
but it shows that you're telling the
truth i respect it
i'm still upset that you try attract a
couple of my friends and that back
won't take it too personally we move we
move
surprised me it was actually a really
good day awesome reals you blood
that one there so i'll be surprised if
she don't come back to man today
you know what i'm trying to say because
the energy the spirit
like bro she wasn't even looking at me
she's looking in me
yeah i would actually see him again yeah
yeah
trust me she likes man the energy's
different it's too much for her to
handle she don't know what to do
yeah i think he did like me i didn't get
grilled can i try grill me and
that's how i told you i to just flip it
up anything she's asking me i'll just go
about that
spin it back on her i actually really
tried to grill him
but every time i just looked at his eyes
i just felt like he was just so nice i
just didn't have it in me to be a [ __ ]
realistically i reckon she'll give my
eight
just because of the track suit american
yeah minimum
no no no we found the one for cheyenne
that wouldn't say the one we'll do
another date maybe
it's on the cards that's what i'm
talking about brother
loved it don't know what to do she'll
sit in there
trust me it's crazy she don't know what
to do trust me she's gonna tell you as
well but
you see that thai guy yeah bring him
back yeah they want me back she wants me
back
like i actually really enjoyed the day i
thought i liked what he had to say
he had substance he seemed like a nice
guy wasn't chatting [ __ ]
i'd actually give him an 8.7
[Music]
you